i haven't just had dinner so i am well
fed and i'm ready to do more s.a.t
problems so we're on section seven
unbait
excuse me maybe i should add drink some
more water
pay uh section seven of the six test on
page 733
problem one
in a certain game points are assigned to
every word
each q x and z in a word sounds like
scrabble is worth five points
and all other letters are worth one
point each so q
x and z are five points each
and the other ones are one point each
what is the sum of the points assigned
to the word exquisite well this is just
x
cui
so what there's let's see which of these
does it has it has an x right so that's
worth five points
and does it have any other um of these
no
it has no has a q right that's worth
five points
it doesn't have a z right
so and so how many one pointers are
there there's
one
two
three four five six seven
so seven one pointers so that's seven
points
plus five plus five plus ten is equal to
seventeen
so that's b so that's really just to
make sure that you don't make careless
mistakes that problem next problem
if you've ever
played scrabble you that problem would
be a joke for you
problem two
if two x minus ten is equal to twenty
two x minus ten
is equal to 20. then x minus 5 is what x
minus 5 is
so the big discovery here is well can i
get just you could solve for x you could
say 2x is equal to 30 x is equal to 15
and then say 15 minus 5 equals 10 or you
could say well this is the same thing as
2 times x minus 10
is equal to 20 divide both sides by 2
x minus 10 is equal to
x minus 10 is equal to 10.
oh sorry maybe that's why you shouldn't
do it this way
all right 2 times x minus 5 x minus 5 is
equal to 10. so that's the other way you
could have done it you just factor out a
2 you get 2 times x minus 5 is 20
divides both sides by 2 you get x minus
5 is 10. the other way is obviously to
say 2x minus 10 is equal to 20.
add 10 to both sides 2x is equal to 30
x is equal to 15.
so then x minus 5 is 15 minus 5 which is
equal to 10.
i don't know which way it might be
faster for you this way might you know
you have to do less thinking and you
just kind of chug through it so you can
just kind of speed along but this way a
few less steps but
maybe you might make a careless mistake
like what i just did but anyway
let's move on hopefully either way you
know how to do it
problem 3.
i'll do it right here
3. if t represents an odd integer which
of the following represents an even
integer so t is an odd integer you know
and and
we can't do this kind of abstractly but
let's just pick a number let's just say
that t is equal to let's what's an odd
integer well 3
3 is an odd integer so let's just say t
equals 2 they didn't say we could pick t
equals 7 who knows so just go through
the choices and say well which one of
those is going to be an even integer
choice a is t plus 2 well 3 plus 2 is 5.
that is still odd so that's not the
right answer
b
2t minus 1. well that's 6 minus 1 that's
5 that's odd
choice c
is 3t minus 2 that's 9 minus 2
9 minus
which is still 7 so that's still odd
choice d
is three t
plus two that's nine plus two
which is equal to eleven right now i'm
just saying t is three that's still odd
and so it's probably going to be e
5t
plus 1
and 15 plus 1 is 16 and that's even
so that's our answer
so sometimes i find it easy if you just
you know pick a number
the other way is if you are familiar
with even and odd numbers you can just
say well the only way to go from an odd
to an even number is you either have to
multiply by
multiply
by
an even number
or
add
an odd number
those are the only way you can go from
an odd number to an even number
so and looking at five t plus one you
could say well when i multiply an odd
number by an odd number i'm going to get
another odd number right
so this number is odd
when i take an odd number and i add 1 to
it i get an even number
so you can say 5t plus 1 is definitely
going to be an even number and it worked
with the
the the odd number that we picked for t
next problem
okay so they drew a picture here
so i will draw a picture here
as best as i can
that's one triangle they drew and this
is the other one looks something like
this
like that
and then this let's say they say this is
a
b
c
this is
d
e
f
and these sides are four
eight
and nine and what are they saying for
the triangles above the perimeter of abc
equals the perimeter of def okay it
equals that
if abc is equilateral what is the length
of a b okay so it's equilateral right
so let's just say that a b is equal to x
well then so is bc and ac because they
told us this is an equilateral triangle
all the sides are equal
and what is the perimeter of abc then
it's going to be x plus x plus x and
that's just 3x
and they say that that's the same thing
as the perimeter of this triangle
what's the perimeter of this triangle
it's four plus eight plus nine
so three x is equal to what's 12
plus nine is 21
x is equal to seven and that is choice c
and we are done
next problem
they have drawn a diagram here that i
will now attempt to draw
okay and then let's see they draw a
dividing line like
looks like it's about a fourth of the
circle then they have another one that's
like a little less than a fourth like
that
and they have one that's like that
roughly
then it goes like
that
and it goes like that
and then they fill in the values too
so this is k
it's 15
j is 25 percent
o let's just call that other is o
other
other is 20
n is 10
m
is 15
and l is 15
and these are sales of jeans in 2001 and
the letters are the brands the circle
graph above represents all the genes
that were sold by a retail store in 2001
according to their brands if this if the
store sold 900 pairs of jeans so this is
the total of all of these is 900 pairs
of jeans
if the store sold
900 pairs of jeans other than brands j k
l m n n n how many did it sell together
okay no so this isn't the total this is
the other this is this is essentially
this category
right
and other is equal to 20 of the total
and that's what they want to ask us how
many did we sell together
so 20 percent of the total so
times t for total let me just say t for
total is equal to 900
and you could also write this as
one-fifth right or point two one-fifth
of the total is equal to nine hundred
multiply both sides by five
all right that cancels out so you get t
is equal to
4 500 pairs of genes and that is choice
e
next problem
oh i thought this problem might apply to
this pie graph but no they're talking
about carpets not genes so i'll do the
next problem in the next video i'll see
you soon